[Music]
you kind of manipulate pushing pushing
this line I Drive the outside of it
right and now you just hanging keys
hanging out here okay
and then you do I move this over seven
push through okay
but most of those things are dependent
on these he's not going to do anything
or I'm stronger than him you see so even
the push through one requires him to
have not so much strength and to wait so
the first thing we do is his energy is
coming in he's got a a pushing energy to
displace do you see so I used that
manner
okay I use this energy to make that
happen so there's a point where it comes
in and I bring it down and the rest of
his body's now passing it you see you
understand and that's totally different
then he's got his energy and he's
pushing and I go like this you see that
he's he's got his pushing energy this
takes no energy it's just a moderate
direction I can't just go down I just
come down but I bring it around the
bottom underneath it you see that and of
course I have to do an anchored elbows
in the strike and everything but that's
what I'm doing
oh he's hit II he's hitting that bottom
my my koku projection here
he's the ground is that lifting that you
saw me do here boom I'm not listening
he's hitting me
boom he's hitting the koku so whoa now
it's been light do you think very slide
and then I move it inside the triangle
always on the bathroom in between the
hip and the elbow and then he'll just
lay down and then I come around this way
it's very slight
[Music]
the tiny little
it says not a strength yes and in the
things in our lives there is all my
colors right those are my two points so
let's slow it down let's get everyone
here be strong okay this is very slight
okay this is where we're gonna start the
next row so step even right feel the
pressure it yields to the fishes this is
going to be that drinking more than
technique but you were doing it in time
ahead go there's the push right and what
did I tell you so set up this row
here we are this is the start of the
room and I'm gonna set it going here
instead of doing this very slight
the drill again here it is Oh No
no lyrics like alright let's try it okay
so I'm trying to get out of focal levers
externals okay so there here's that
here's the energy was charging up in the
prescribed energy analytical Bible and I
get it to bounce over me and that's the
demonstration of cooking he comes around
oh he hit something father and his
inertia takes his mask over that bottom
hole for a minute goes okay so I feel
that oh alright but not feel that too
you see that requires there's a charge
right genesee but there's no more energy
then I can deflect over and the you
what we do is I start shutting people
down and when you do that you stop doing
the heart so energy comes in oh I feel
that and I'm gonna yield it okay so I
want you guys to energetic
oh he feels the initial percussion then
there's a class it's my job to reconcile
the class okay
and what we know from our own training
we're not push you which is what
happened on the first one in
psychologically you're gonna push back
so I can use that to get around I let
you go by so I can enter this is a much
better position than this one you say
are you mediator to go yield this one
okay up to that point okay so I've been
exaggerating things so you can see the
moments in the patterns like it can't be
that way okay so that's why the first
one looks like the are manipulation but
the kid goes whoa that was totally
different
okay but the same thing goes on so as I
come around here oh there's going to be
a flexion that happens right in time
reflection the pressure the accumulation
of energy the pressurization of
and the releasing of energy that's the
perfume so you you will feel that as you
go it's inside so you feel it probably a
structural alignment at this point but
as you come around here that's where
pressure starts to accumulate right and
we come around and my stomach will come
out and usually to feel that okay don't
push it
just touch so whoa it's nothing as weak
as I start to bring his energy okay and
that's what he feels now when I do this
watch it watch his body watch his body
is it moving
yeah it's moving but I have to move my
arm so the unit manifestation is let it
pass disappear itself you see inside not
like that so I'm going to do all the we
were together and everything is inside
you see so I don't make this baby other
circle on the technique do you see this
light over here that was it but he feels
it you guys he feels there was some like
inertia and then all of a sudden
[Music]